should we interpret the recruitment of
spider-man by Tony Stark as him using
child soldiers and if so what's it say
to it Allen's character a bit heavy
you know it's perhaps the most powerful
child soldier in the world yeah he's um
look there's a certain narcissism to the
character and you know Tony doesn't want
to lose this fight at the same time I
think he also sees a Spider Man as the
greatest living non-lethal weapon if
you're going out to capture a bunch of
people who you don't necessarily want to
hurt you couldn't ask for a better
character than spider-man to take with
you he does show up and and and you know
illustrate that spider-man he knows how
powerful he is in a video where we see
spider-man stopping a car moving 40
miles an hour
where he catches it and puts it back on
the ground so I think he believes that
he's taking with him perhaps one of the
most powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe and I think he feels like the
kid will be well protected under his
tutelage you also find out in that
sequence when things go wrong the kid
says what do I do and Tony says keep
your distance Webb them up so he's
already he's he's obviously mentored the
kid for what's about to go down but it's
still very irresponsible and Robert can
you a little bit about about working
with Tom because that scene in
particular where you arrive at his house
in his bedroom so it's wonderful and
just about how you first met on what
that meeting was like in him being cast
well now that two out of three Spider
Men are English I really uh I really got
to talk my book McGwire off the ledge
now but mr. Hollin anyone who
experienced him you know he's uh he's
not a work in progress I mean he's
really something else
and I think by the way folks reacted to
this I mean it's always you know it's a
good new anyone you know I think he
really came on with a with a
and there's a lot of excitement about
seeing what will happen when he kind of
holds its own you know
you